okay good evening ladies and gentlemen
and members it is six o'clock so we will
get started welcome to tonight's
planning committee my name is councillor
richards i will be chairing this
evening's meeting
um a few housekeeping uh items are for
me to start with we're not expecting a
fire alarm but if there is one
follow us it's probably the easiest
thing to do we'll meet in the car park
and we'll just make sure everyone is
is safe and okay and if you could please
set your
phones preferably off but silent is also
fine which as long as it doesn't
interrupt the proceedings of the meeting
that's that's great
um and just to note that we are being
recorded
and streamed live so uh just be aware of
that um
throughout the meeting please the
meeting is
a meeting in public it is not a public
meeting so only those people
have registered to speak will be
permitted to do so
i will call you forward at the
appropriate time if you could please put
on your masks
when you're moving between you're okay
to leave them off while you're sat down
but when you're moving between your seat
and
the table if you could please put your
mask on you can take it off again once
you sat down
um and when you're done if you could
please there are some wipes and some
hand sanitizers if you could please wipe
the desk very quickly and sanitize your
hands before and after that would be
much appreciated
okay um let me please introduce
some of our officers next so we have
from community services we have olivia
quinn mason nash our solicitor
heather kenny uh we have stuart flaherty
tony horton
is here somewhere and richard gardner
who is our planning manager richard i
think you probably have a statement to
make
thank you very much indeed right let's
get into the main part of the agenda so
apologies for absence first of all
please
chair we have apologies from councillors
adam curtis and mills
thank you very much do we have any
disclosures of interest from our members
please counselor dixon first
thank you chairman uh item five
application 21-0
springbrook lane in my award i'm the
ward member and i will be
speaking on behalf of the applicant so i
shall withdraw from the committee at
that time
lovely staff thank you very much
councillor kendall
thank you chairman um the final item uh
item six
i'm a member of wells born walton parish
council but i have abstained on this
application so i feel i can stay on the
committee
thank you marvelous thank you very much
um for myself i
am the ward member for the first two
items um on item one which is the old
butcher shop in claverden
i've made no representations and i am
here with an open mind so i'll
remain on the committee for that for the
second item which is bray house i have
made representations and i will be
speaking so
i will be stepping away and handing over
the reins to councillor kendall
for that item good in that case
let's get straight into it so our first
application is 203306
ful and 20 three zero seven
lbc the old butcher shop in cleveland
are presenting officers church floyd
stewart over to you thank you chairman
good evening everybody
um this proposal is seeking full
planning permission enlisted building
consent for the erection of a dwelling
the application site is within the
adopted build sprayer boundary of
clavedon
indicated by the black dots on this
slide
here we see a plan denoting the location
of the site
the black line here shows the
application boundary
uh you can see we reside within a
conservation area
as detailed by the purple line in
addition to a number of listed buildings
both in the immediate
and wider vicinity we are also in a site
washed over by the green belt
in addition to being in a highly
sensitive archaeological area
and residing within the arden special
landscape area
here we have the proposed site layout
plan showing the footing of where the
proposed dwelling is to be cited
and associated works
here we see both the existing and
proposed elevational detail as viewed
from the main frontage on the highway
here on the left here and then again
here on the proposed we see
the grade 2 listed old butcher's shop
dwelling here we see some indicative
imagery of how
the dwelling would sit in the wider area
one can see there is detailing here with
where my cursor is currently hovering
over where
the design of this dwelling
no such detail is on the surrounding
built form but it gives an indicative
uh glimpse of the proposed development
we now have some photos of the site
itself
here we are still on the footpath
looking north eastward
one can see that the site is vacant and
previous structures that were they
historically have since been demolished
you can also see neighbouring dwellings
a small snapshot of one there
one there and the uh grade two butcher's
shop there
here we are still on the opposite side
the highway looking at the dwelling from
a
more zoomed out point of view um one can
see
uh more detail of that neighboring
property there
and how this space here would be used to
accommodate this development
here we see the old garage structure
that is supposed to be demolished to
help accommodate this proposed
development
here we are stood looking at the
frontage looking southwards
um where one can see the grade two
listed dwelling there
and this structure here uh also part of
the grade two listing that is to be
proposed to be incorporated into the
proposed dwelling
and finally we are just looking here
opposite the sites just to get a small
snapshot of some of the other dwellings
in the immediate vicinity
um harm has been identified by officers
to the significance of the heritage
assets in the area
the cumulative impact of this
development detrimentally impacts on
historic character
the induction introduction of this
dwelling and associated development is
deemed to be an incongruous addition
um that is not sensitive to the area
harm is identified additionally to the
neighboring properties
by virtue of its scale and height and
amounts to what is a visibly dominant
structure
please refer everybody to the update
sheets which includes matters such as
the member site visit that took place on
monday
chairman the recommendation is to refuse
both these applications for the reasons
set on pages 13 and 14 of your agenda
thank you
barbara stuart thank you very much and
we'll move to our first speaker who is
our agent mr steve
um alison steve please do come forward
whichever you like
so steve i think you know the drill
you've been here a few times before so
you'll have three minutes
whenever you're ready do feel free to
start and i'll give you a 30 second
warning before we at the end and then i
shall let you know when the three
minutes is up
otherwise over to you
good evening my name is steve elson i'm
a chartered architect at brock charles
and we are agent for the applicant
we met here two weeks ago and the
councillors agreed to defer the planning
decision
subject to a site visit and which
happened on monday this week
where we looked at the existing dwelling
heights and the proximity of the new
dwelling to the listed building
what i trust was clearly shown is that
the council's only concerns were
completely satisfied
and the approval of the development here
tonight would remove a long-standing
eyesore
hopefully the planning officer will have
shown you an annotated street scene
drawing
with all of the surrounding dwelling
ridge heights now added
i also confirmed these at monday's visit
and it is clear that the dwelling is
between the high
and lower ridge heights along the green
we also looked at how close the dwelling
was to the listed building
what was not made clear by the planning
office at the last committee meeting
is the retained store building that
matches the ridge height of the listed
dwelling and buffers the new build part
of the home
the retained store is repurposed as the
kitchen
downstairs toilet on one of the ensuite
bathrooms
and is 5.8 meters long so the transition
in height
rises at over 9.3 meters or 30 feet away
from the nearest part of the listed
building the store has matching
victorian detailing
and this continues in the new part of
the dwelling
the committee sorry the committee
members who visited on monday
were also pleasantly surprised by how
large the site area is
and this may not be clear from looking
at the drawings
there is ample space for the garden
amenity and off street parking
and the demolition of the existing
garage for a low brick boundary
perimeter walls will open
up and soften the streetscape this is a
limited infill
within the green belt so it's acceptable
there are larger houses within the
proximity that's listed dwelling
so there is no harm or dominance here to
a heritage asset
and some properties even have less
architectural merit
than this home the site remains a
derelict eyesore
the proposed home is surrounded by by
both higher and lower dwellings along
the green
and matches their materials you can see
this clearly on our street scene
drawings
only the planning and conservation
officers are objecting to this
application
and with vague conclusions along with
some neighbors who still want to block
traffic along the narrow road and park
cars across the pavement
we witnessed this on monday and you will
have seen the photos when we last
met you can see why your highways
department does not object to this
application
in fact no one else does thank you for
your time
and i'm happy to answer any questions
thank you very much members do we have
any questions
our agent don't rush at once no
okay in that case steve thank you very
much indeed
and we will carry on if you don't mind
while you while you do your stuff so
thank you very much
okay members uh do we have any technical
questions or points of clarification for
our officer
please indicate now if you do yep
council jennings thank you
thank you the house immediately behind
the building um one proposed building
um the bridge height of that is is what
and how does it compare to this new
to the proposal
thank you councillor um i believe it's
this property here you're
referring to yeah yeah so um
the agent mr elson is absolutely correct
um there is
a street scene plan that has been
provided it was submitted to us on
monday
and this has been added into your slides
this evening
um there is some indicative imagery here
to show that relationship to the
dwelling which if you can see my cursor
i believe it's that property there and
how it sits
um i i urge slight caution on this and
that on the plan itself it does say it's
not to scale this is an indicative image
um i in terms of how it sits in relation
we've obviously
seen it on sites that's the dwelling
there in question
um i don't have a definitive ridge
height for you
but i can say that um the proposed ridge
height
is to be 7.6 meters that is to be
measured from
there which is approximately
commensurate with that dwelling
behind immediately when you're referring
to there
okay thank you okay anyone else for any
points of clarification if not we'll
move into the debate
okay in that case let's open up the
debate who would like to kick us off
gosh you're all very quiet tonight
no one thank you councillor dixon
thank you chairman guys it's certainly
my concern when uh we were last here
was very much the potential mass of that
proposed dwelling and i wanted to see
the site and it was my proposal that we
indeed
attend the site visit that clarified in
my own mind
um that the site to my mind does need
redevelopment
but my concern and i think might
possibly be shared
by others i'm not sure but personally it
was the potential impact
not on the existing listed building
not on the premises
across the road but the one property
at number two clover down i think it is
um which is the one that council
jennings has just asked for the
the ridge height for etc now the
spacing between the two the proposed new
dwelling
i think it will be a rear elevation of
that which then faces a side elevation
of clover now are there any windows
that we should be concerned with and
then the overlooking the space between
the two
i know from the report i think is less
than
our own guidelines but equally well
that might apply to any building that
was actually put onto this
site which um i would like to think is
not going to be
ended as a as an empty plot indefinitely
so i'm minded to think that we ought to
be granting approval for this one
but i'm equally well interested in
hearing other views
thank you chairman thank you very much
councilor jennings did you indicate
cancer joining me and last time
my concern was
certainly the rich heights after
visiting the site
and getting an idea of exactly where it
was going to come
on the house behind and also looking
from
the property off to the left there's
quite a tall building there
so what i thought was was a very large
basmati
wasn't as big as i actually
turned out to be so again
i'm sort of sitting on the fence on on
this one
um it's it's an absolute eyesore it has
to be something has to be done there
and i know there's been many
applications on this and it doesn't seem
to be getting anywhere
um this one seems like a reasonable
a reasonable application so again
i'm reserve judgment at the moment and
i'll look forward to other people's
opinions
okay thank you very much um does anyone
else want to come in on a debate at this
point
no i better put my two pennies worth in
then in that case
um i'm gonna propose we grant this
uh and i'm going to do that on a similar
basis to what we've just heard
in my mind that site is an absolute i
saw it's central to the conservation
area
the point of conservation areas to
conserve it at the moment it's just
dilapidated buildings bricks a building
site
it shouldn't be it needs to be brought
back into use as soon as possible
um it has been a long time uh through
the planning process as you'll see
um i think this is an ideal opportunity
for me the
proposed doesn't uh impact the uh
streets here if anything it hunt
enhances the street scene given the uh
the state the the site is in at the
moment
the removal of the garage at the moment
just a big red brick wall
i think definitely enhances the the
street scene in the the conservation
area so
for those reasons i'm wanting to grant
or i'm proposing to grant and i will
look for a seconder
cancer fielding
for the same reasons that you have
announced or said and the same reasons
that i
asked for it to be approved last time
but it needs to be dealt with
thank you very much does anyone else
want to have anything to say on the
debate at this point
council crumb thank you chair
oh i'm sorry councillor crump first and
then yourself
cancer crump i think it says before
beauty so i've got to go first peter
so i've got to go first so hey
there we are i think i think you've got
the best of that one
sorry cancer uh which is uh just um
it's just about the conditions i'm happy
to go along with this as well
um and make sure we've got the highways
matters conditioned as in
uh on page 11 so if that could be
mentioned
thank you we will come to the conditions
in just a moment if anyone at the
council hands you seriously want to come
in at this point
yes thank you chair um yes having paid a
side visit
and because derral derelict sites been
there for so long
it's it can't go on like that and i
think it will enhance the street scene
um people need a place to live
so i would go for grant thank you
lovely thank you very much so before we
go to grant we do need to
uh just confirm with our um planning
officers and manager that
they're happy with the process we've
gone through and
to detail any conditions that you would
want to attach to a
proposal to grant um thank you mr
chairman
um from what i'm hearing from members
it seems to me that the level of harm
identified by officers isn't mirrored by
the committee
i.e um considering that there's no harm
if you consider that there's some harm
then you need very uh sorry you need
public benefits to outweigh it
and you won't see any in the offices
report
but it seems to me that the talk of the
site's neglected state being important
here i'd uh caution with that because
paragraph 196 of the mppf says that
where there's evidence
of deliberate neglect or damage there's
no question of damage in this case
to a heritage asset the deteriorated
state of the heritage asset
should not be taken into account in any
decision so i'd
urge caution with that if um
it would be better if members to my mind
judged that it wasn't causing harm at
all than to say it's causing some level
of harm
and used the neglected state as a public
benefit because of the contrary to the
mppf
so those would be my thoughts on that um
having
proposed this um i can confirm that i
don't believe there to be
uh any harm um the fact that it's going
to improve the site
uh is of public benefit in my mind but
that is not what i'm using as a reason
to outweigh
any harm i don't believe that to be any
cancer folding can you confirm
that you agree with that i do agree with
that and
there it needs to be dealt with there's
very little harm
in improving the screen scene and i like
to go
forward marvelous thank you very much um
do you standard conditions presumably do
you have any others that you would like
to add we obviously heard that we
the the traffic one from cancer uh yes
thank you chairman um
we do have a crude list of conditions
which
perhaps when playing manager perhaps
corroborate but whether you're we're
happy to delegate that to offices or not
or whether we need to discuss them
out loud right now that's perhaps
something from my manager and
yourself to discuss um i'm happy to read
through the headlines of those
conditions
and then perhaps have delegated
authority for the detailed wording
that's exactly what i'd like please okay
so
for for the full application the
conditions would be there would be 11 in
total so we've got
standard three years approved plans
samples of materials landscaping and
boundary detail
highways parking and turning area the
climate change checklist
archaeology a construction management
plan
um electric vehicle charging points
uh and then a requirement for a water
boot and a requirement for bins
so that's a total of 11 conditions and
three notes
concerning the mppf ecology and fire and
rescue
marvelous thank you very much i'm happy
with that john i'm going to assume
you're happy with that
now we do have to take these uh
independently so we'll have the the full
application first of all so the proposal
is to grant for the reasons given
including detail in the update sheet
we have a show of hands for those in
favor please
marvelous in that case uh committee
resolves to
grant sorry i've lost my number uh grant
application reference twenty
zero three three zero six ful we now
look at the lbc
so for the same reasons the proposal is
to grant with the uh conditions we've
heard and the reasons given
if we could please have a show of hands
for those in favor
in that case committee resolves to grant
application twenty zero three three zero
seven
lbc marvelous thank you very much
members now it is uh my turn to hand
over
to our sorry um sorry can i interject
here that there would need to be
conditions presumably on the listed
building consent
forgive me um i thought for some reason
i thought you'd have
to do them in exactly yeah please please
do it again yeah
so there would be eight on this a
three-year condition
approved plans samples of materials
archaeology
large scale details of eaves elevations
and verges
and then a separate one for large scale
details of windows and doors
structural components to support
existing structures
and finally works to make good any
damage to the fabric
and a note on the mppf
we're going to do that john can you
confirm you're happy with those
conditions
lovely thank you very much if we could
please have a show of hands those in
favor of granting
unanimous again thank you very much so
we therefore have resolved
to grant um i will take leave and pass
over to the capable hands of councillor
kendall
okay hope you all hear me okay
we move then to uh item four on our
agenda tonight this is
application reference twenty slash zero
zero seven
four five slash fuel it's for bray house
langley road
langley road cleveland and it's the
erection of two uh two meter high timber
fence
adjacent to the highway as presenting
officer stuart flaherty again stewart
over to you
thank you chairman um this proposal
seeking full permission as the chairman
has just touched upon
for the erection of a two-meter high
timber fence adjacent to the public
highway
uh the application site is in an area of
open countryside indicated by the black
dots on this plan just outside the
village of claverden
we are in an area washed over by
greenbelt in addition to being an arden
special landscape
area here we see the location plan
as submitted by the applicant um
in addition to the red line boundary
denoting the site uh
one can see a sort of quite faint blue
line here denoting where the post
fencing is to go
um there is a more embellished version
of that plan here
um this is the existing arrangement uh
in front of bray house
this is the proposed fencing uh to run
in front of the house and then along the
existing brick wall
similarly here we see elevational detail
showing the existing arrangement and
what is proposed
here we have a cross-sectional detail
showing the existing brick wall in situ
as is currently and what is proposed to
retain that brick wall but to have a
approximate two metre high timber fence
behind it
we now have some photos of the site this
is said house in question bray house
uh the fencing is proposed along this
frontage here
uh this is slightly more zoomed in
version showing the brick wall which is
approximately a meter high
here we are just looking southwards at
the same property on the same wall
um that concludes my presentation please
refer
to the update sheets uh for relevant
updates
um chairman the recommendation is to
refuse this application for the reasons
given on page 22 of your gender packs
thank you
thank you stuart okay we moved to our
first speaker on this application that's
ms emma bowton hope i'm pronouncing that
correctly
thank you come on up
welcome right so um if you have three
minutes to speak
we'll give you a warning of the last 30
seconds if that's okay
and if you'd remain seated for any
questions at the end all right over to
you
so good evening mr chairman and
committee clearly in the three minutes
afforded me to state my case i'm not in
a position to go point by point through
this whole document
so let me summarize by stating the key
facts in this matter
firstly in the spirit of doing things
correctly i did of course apply for
planning permission
but in doing so i did not expect too
many issues
the request does not seem to contribute
any legal regulations
quite rightly the main issue is one of
safety and therefore it is good to see
that we have no objections now from the
highways department
after some compromise by ourselves i
would also like to point out
that the extent of the timber fencing is
to simply add on top of an existing
feature brick wall
a 90 centimeter fence which is entirely
consistent
with the cladding on the house this
would mean that the total height would
not exceed 1.8 meters
it is worth pointing out that in the
original planning permission for the
development
permission was granted for a 1.8 metre
brick wall
it is irrelevant that the developer
later chose to amend the design
at a height of 1.8 meters i would also
point out that it is lower than the
existing hedge which it butts up to
it is worth noting that the points cited
in the planning officers report
are not legal regulations but rather
they are guidelines for considerable
consideration regarding greenbelt the
reason for these guidelines is to allow
for common sense decisions to be made
we are therefore at a loss to understand
the planning officer's recommendations
that a hedge may be planted with a fence
behind it
as this seems to defy logic if a hedge
is erected then the fence behind it will
not be required
the one local objector claims that there
would be a loss of view if the fence
were erected
but if a hedge were planted the view
would be lost for good anyway
so in summary in light of the fact that
there are no longer any highway
objections
significantly no claverden parish
council objections
and cleveland parish council is not
known for its laissez-faire attitude
towards greenbelt
we have the support of our local
councillor and the design is in keeping
with the housing development
then i would like to think that the
common sense decision in this case is to
give approval
not for a 1.8 meter fence but a 90
centimeter fence
on top of an existing feature brick wall
which is entirely in keeping with the
setting
thank you for your time and i would ask
you that that you grant planning
permission for this proposal
thank you uh do we have any questions
from the committee council jennings
evening did you consider planting hedge
there
we did yes and there was a number of
reasons why we would prefer
fence um the first is that a hedge
wouldn't
uh give us the immediate privacy and
security that we would like for our two
children as you can see from the picture
that was presented it is quite open we
often have lots of people stop and try
and engage us in conversation and chat
to the kids and we wanted something
immediate
the second consideration is that there
are quite stringent requirements for
adhering to visibility display
and clearly a hedge would require some
continual maintenance to make sure that
we adhere to the the guidelines that the
highways authority have set out
and so a fence seemed to to resolve that
that potential ongoing maintenance issue
of making sure that people could see
when leaving the drive
and so one follow-up question are there
any other houses down that road who have
got
uh so along langley road yes there's a
mixture of different frontages
um within the immediate vicinity um
there is
a fence at the the neighboring property
mulberry which matches the design albeit
believe that it's in the document they
haven't got planning consent for that
and it was there when the developer
built the property
but actually we haven't got any close
neighboring properties there's quite a
lot of land between the
us and the next house um so actually if
you go to the full extent of langley
road there's an eclectic mix of
frontages yeah
right okay
there are no further questions in that
case thank you very much for your time
tonight thank you very much
okay we'll go to our next speak uh board
member councillor richards
thank you chairman welcome councilman
richards i won't go through the whole
spiel you know it
over to you i know we're at marvelous
thank you very much members thank you
for for listening to me tonight um
so to my way of thinking there are two
reasons uh in the recommendations for
that have been presented as refusals and
i'm gonna address that i'm gonna try and
address those each in turn there is some
overlap so first of all
looking at reason one um it appears that
the officer considers there is a harmful
visual impact
on the character and openness of the
street scene as you've already heard and
for those of you who undertook an
independent site visit you'll know
that langley road and church road merged
just slightly up from from where we are
here
and along that entire street scene there
is an eclectic mix of
frontages including hedgerows two meter
high uh fences
some close boarded some interwoven uh
some open bordered
so for me i can't see how introducing
a similar uh fence could change the
street scene uh materially uh in this
area
looking to um uh reason number two uh
which
revolves around greenbelt you'll see on
page 19
of your report um part b of cs10 uh
allows for small-scale extensions
alterations of buildings but
specifically
um says that they they must not cause
material
harm to the openness of the green belt
the key point there i want you to draw
out is material
um i'm struggling to understand how a
small two meter
fence in this location could cause a
material
uh or cause material harmful to the
green belt you'll all know
the mppf specifically states that the
green belt is there to prevent
urban sprawl um it obviously goes into
further detail
but the key thread or the key point is
to prevent urban sprawl
clearly we're not talking about urban
sprawl um in this location
so to my mind um as i say this this
is in keeping and fits with the uh
existing street scene
uh throughout the village of captain
along the langley road
um i don't believe that it caused
material harm to the openness of the
greenbelt and therefore i believe
it is um not considered inappropriate
development and should be allowed under
part b
of course strategy policy cs10 however
if you don't agree with me on that point
um as you have also heard this is for
safety and security reasons
the family live there um as we've heard
have young children
you'll see the play areas in the back
garden from the photos the last thing
one wants on a road like that is
children hopping over the fence and
getting run down
it is purely for safety and privacy
reasons um so very special circumstances
are
exactly that so if you need if you feel
that this does cause material harm to
the openness of the green belt
those are your special circumstances i
would
urge you to consider the former where it
is not material
thank you thank you thank you any
questions for the ward member
none in that case thank you council
richards
you're free to step down uh we'll move
then two points of clarification
anybody got any points yes councillor
dixon
thank you chairman the planning officer
has
been putting up a slide showing a fence
behind a wall
can we have that and can we understand
exactly where that
is is that the proposal or is that in a
neighboring property
which is erected without permission
thank you councillor um i can address
all of those queries i hope
uh this is a timber fence that is on a
property
immediately next to this property a
property called mulberry house
so i have a visual here
this picture was taken where my cursor
is there
uh on that fence along there um planning
permission
was refused for that offence um a
proposal was put in retrospectively
um a delegated refusal was issued for
that approximately
three to four weeks ago by
by this district it is approximately the
same
i believe it is the same height at two
meters as is proposed this evening
uh one can see the proximity to where
that property is at mulberry compared to
where we are at bray house
um i believe the officer also touches on
that further in the
uh agenda pack also but i'm happy to
clarify that
so that's imagery you saw i'll just show
it again
for reference um there that
is at the immediate neighboring property
mulberry house
um it's it's it's in its infancy it
would appear it was this was refused
approximately three to four weeks ago
it may go to appeal we're not sure we
could counsel dixon
a further question if i may stuart um
the
there was a change i believe um
following the reports etc regarding
sight lines because i think obviously
there was initially
a proposal that the brick wall would be
higher than has been than has been
constructed
has it been constructed at its current
height in order to achieve
those sight lines and had it been
originally built to a two meter
with those sight lines have been
achieved
thank you um i will try to address that
question as best i can um
as mrs borton has correctly said um work
has been taken place i understand
between the applicant
and uh this district and the highways
department whereby there was initial
concern
raised on matters of visibility splays
and highways
that matter as it's been detailed in the
reports and as was touched upon just now
i think i
consider we consider a since been
resolved um i can't give you a
definitive answer as to the how and when
and why
um in terms of previous revised plans et
cetera and whatnot but
we are satisfied from a visibility splay
point of view from highways and safety
and our own opinion and also guided by
county highways we are satisfied that
the visibility aspect is acceptable
okay council jennings
thank you so um a couple of questions um
it was raised that uh in the original
application to
to do all the building that it that you
could have had they could have had a 1.8
meter
brick wall at the front is that
is that correct um yes i had to field
that question
um i i referred to page 18 on the on the
planet and your genopax in planning
history
um the original permission uh
that was issued in 2017 allows the
direction of four houses
i believe that plan uh had a perimeter
war that was 1.8 meters i think that was
also touched upon
um by by our speaker this evening um
there is then an amd
a non-material amendment application in
2019
where that boundary wall was was
applied to be reduced and indeed was
down to one meter which is the meter
that we see
on the imagery there um the reasoning
the how and why is to why that was
applied for
um is the business of the applicant and
and
that's a previous approval that's
already been issued so um
that plan history is materially relevant
clearly but um
they've got approval to have reduced the
ball the wall that indeed have done
done so okay and next question is safety
and security
is that a material planning
consideration it
is a consideration again i defer to to
the officer's report
um i page 21 um that has been
considered in the conclusion and
planning balance section
um it has been put forward i believe as
a vsc in light of this being deemed to
be inappropriate development the green
belt
um i'm guided by officers report which
states that
that has been considered to answer your
question but that that has not been
deemed to be outweigh the harm caused
not given that much weight it's been
considered but it's not deemed to
outweigh the harm
to the green belt i would also just draw
your attention to the same part of the
report where
the officer gives reference to um
another property
just down the road where similar
situation where an inspector dismissed
a woven fence on the grounds that uh
security and privacy didn't outweigh the
harm caused
so they weren't a very special
circumstance in that case it's further
down the road but obviously it's in the
same green belt so it's relevant
so and is that the property which you
just mentioned the one
when you come out of the this particular
property you turn right
it's quite a way down it's and it's
about two meters or so in height
i can yeah thank you i i'm happy to
answer that counselor uh it is yes it's
about 300 meters up the road heading
back in towards the village it's a
property called the fieldings
uh on the langley road um there's a
recent determination by the inspector
i've actually got it right in front of
me actually it was issued in february of
this year
um there was identified greenbelt harm
in that instance and
um was found to uh that that
decision was dismissed by the inspector
in february it's about 300 meters
away from this site approximately
thank you yes councillor crump
councillor jen has
asked half my question about the war but
didn't quite carry on in the same
direction as me
so back in 2017 a
1.8 meter brick wall
was given approval prior to the
amendment
and therefore a 1.8 meter brick wall was
deemed
not to harm the green belt or
be less than substantial harm to the
green belt
yeah a couple years later on so
now i start um um if so if the amendment
hadn't come in there could be a 1.8
meter
wall there um because it got approval
for that
but no because the um developer
applicant decided to have a
one meter brick wall and now the
applicant has come in to
increase that to 1.8 1.9 meters whatever
it is apologies for the wrong ones
that is deemed to be unacceptable
in the green belt i'm just slightly
struggling
how that happens um
i'm gonna pressure we're trying to form
a question here i think yeah
um i think it's how why is there a
material difference and between
that's no pun intended between a fence
award and brick
when it comes to the effect of a 1.8
brick ball
as opposed to being acceptable in the
original planning application
whereas we've got a 1.9 wooden fence
um so why so what's different and why is
there a material difference
eventually i'm happy
thank you council i'm happy to fill that
question um
officers can only assess the schemas
before them at this current time
officer has made a determination based
on what's been proposed in this
application
um the one
small difference perhaps between then
and now the development plan has changed
slightly the
the cleveland neighbor development plan
for example has since been adopted where
it wasn't in 2017 for example
um the planning history as you stated
there
you are correct that a scheme was
approved
in 2017 that scheme was considered a
little merits and this scheme here this
evening
uh at committee has been considered on
its own merits as well
um i don't know if my manager didn't add
to that as well yeah i mean
the important thing there is that
they're different developments one is
one is wall
higher quality materials and most
importantly to me one is two meters
the one before you tonight the previous
one was 1.8 meters high so that then
there's comparisons but they're not
exactly the same
okay thank you so it don't count as
trump it was a question i was mulling
over as well so thank you
council dixon
thank you chairman a very quick one does
the
applica does the approval for the wall
still exist could it be done i
appreciate there was an amendment which
allowed the wall to be reduced
but could a 1.8 meter wall be
constructed
given that it has permission which has
not been implemented but nevertheless
permission
i don't think i'm going to be able to
give you an answer to that because it's
it's a question we'd have to dig into
the legalities of it in terms of whether
that permission's been spent
i suspect the permission's been spent
now and he's superseded by what we had
before but i couldn't give a definitive
no
to that question
if it had been started
i'm gonna pull away from that i think
it's speculative i think
i think we're speculating and given the
planning manager can't give us any more
i think it's unlikely to still be valid
simply because a different development
has taken place either one meter high
capped wall is the one that's taken
place and
a 1.8 meter height capped wall is a
different development
um but i as i said i i couldn't give you
a definitive no for that
all right go on
yeah just to confirm we're talking about
a two meter high timber fence
am i correct on that thank you uh
councillor chairman uh
a two meter fence is in the descriptive
development that's what's been applied
for
i'm guided by imagery on your screen
right now which is a plan provided by
the applicant which shows
a extent that goes to two meters um
this has been assessed as thus um and
has been um
put to committee this evening
okay let's go to the debate who wants to
kick us off
anybody keen
jennings followed by councillor dixon
yeah i mean i
i drove i drove down there and i drove
into all
all of the driveways and sort of and
looked at all the fencing of all what
was going on and what was there
what's there now and obviously
you then realize that half the half of
the fencing there's
has been done illegally um
or shouldn't shouldn't be there i'm just
gonna end up being taken down
um when you look at a
fence certainly gives you privacy and i
can absolutely understand that
um and if i was living there and
had children i wouldn't i would want
something there
um
but i guess we're back to this rules
those rules um
i'm sorry that's out i'm looking for a
way
which i could possibly go against the
officer's
decision here but i can't actually see
one
captain
thank you chairman um i can't see a
reason for going against the officer's
recommendation
it's not actually to my mind a matter of
a building in the green belt as the
fence is uh
essentially but to my mind it's a street
scene
and we are in a it's a rural area
and it the
wall fence is an urbanizing feature
and i think the current design is fine
i note that obviously
there is a brick wall as opposed to a
hedge
but certainly in the rural parts of this
district i think hedges and vegetation
are to be preferred to fences
on the side of the roads and the
boundaries
especially when we're talking about two
meter high
certainly i've got issues in my own ward
where
enforcement are equally taking place so
um i will be supporting the officer's
recommendation on this one
thank you anybody else want to speak yes
councillor trump
just give me the opportunity to say i
won't be sitting on the fence on this
one sorry about that
um got one or two smiles here
um yeah um i'll i'll probably
i did the counter argument um i i'll
personally i think
i've seen too many problems with this
small scale and
not particularly causing material harm
to the openness
of part b of cs10 um on
the different view regarding hedges
compared to fences
um hedges unless they're kept under
control
uh tend to cause a lot more problems
than fences fences sometimes move
sometimes fall over
but invariably half the problems um i've
got community
with one of my other hats on are caused
by hedges suddenly growing out all over
the place
not being kept under control um and
certainly don't always add to the
visibility
um and safety of road safety
so i would propose
i might be on my own but i propose that
we go against officers recommendation
and
grant the application thank you
well we've had a proposal do we have a
seconder for that
council hench seraphin do you wish to
speak on this
yeah looking at it safety
of children is paramount i think and uh
it's very wise that families take this
into account
i would have probably preferred hedging
but that takes a long time to grow
um i see that it's not condensed
there's no houses that near there's not
that many houses in that road so
now i propose that we can grant this
alongside cancer crumb thank you
council do you want to come in yeah i'm
just going to ask a question
is is the main reason for the objection
the height of the fence
or are you is there what i'm saying is
is there talking space for you and the
applicant
to decide that if they come back with a
slightly different proposal with a
different height
that that would make a difference but
it's just
that the grounds is the height the main
stumbling block for this
or is it just the pure construction of
the fence anyway
i'm minded that this is slightly
speculative and not strictly
but i think it might help the debate
slightly so i'm going to give you a bit
of ground on it
i'm guided by the wording
for reasons plural offers um
second only officers can only consider
the proposals for them
um this one found that this proposal was
becoming
unacceptable um i can't speculate as to
if it wants his word to be reduced
etcetera but that would need to be
okay okay right
does anybody else want to speak we do
have a proposal
and a second and i want yes i want to
come to the reasons
um what i heard then was a combination
of the following that well basically
council
correct me if i'm wrong but you were
saying you the fact that it was a
fence rather than hedging you thought
actually led to being um
no material harm to the openness of the
green belt
am i right in that or am i going in the
wrong direction yeah
or less yeah yeah less harm
and it's small scale um
i think it's part b of cs10 and i think
counts the riches was that right
um so not causing material harm to
openness
in relation to um to the area to the
street scene
um that was my my main ones but if we we
do need some more um
we'll have a thing if we don't
necessarily need more i don't think
can i go to the offices and get a bit of
an opinion on that as a reason for
going for granting this one richard
perhaps you
i'm just struggling with the notion that
the offense is better than a hedge in
the green belt
um it's the countryside
any fence is more urbanizing than a
hedge or nothing at all
that that's i mean that's a fact it's
whether it
it it's more harmful in this case and
obviously
um it's not a traditional form of incl
closure the traditional form of
enclosure on a rural lane like this
would be hedgerows maintained hedgerows
uh kept down either by the farmer or in
a domestic case with the
with the trimmer so that's why reason
one is in there so i'm struggling a bit
with
with what i've heard um but obviously
members are entitled to make their own
decision on this
thank you councillor crumb but haven't
we got a wall there already because we
don't see normally many walls down the
country line um so that's sort of like
yeah
defeats that argument a bit if we you
know um
if we hadn't got the wall there i think
it'd be slightly different but we've
already got some form of urbanization of
the
of the of the plot um so
that's that's mine coming from there not
regarding the fence
i got there's two reasons one because i
think it's more difficult to maintain
there are potential issues and from my
experience it might not
necessarily apply 100 here but in my
experience hedges can
detract from the visibility and also
have concerns on on
road safety and also um we have
mentioned that
from the security point of view which i
think is slightly discounted but the
security view
offenses put um almost immediate whereas
a hedge takes a significant amount of
time to come to re
regard heightened thickness so that's
that's my concerns
that's right okay well we've got a set
of reasons richard
i'm i'm not sure you're going to love
them yeah but i think
i don't think we're moving any anywhere
further i think
if committee are happy to do this i
think we've got some reason i say put it
to a vote and see what happens
can i just clarify one point though
about the obviously i've talked about
the urbanizing impact that's reason one
there's reason two to overcome as well
which is the green belt one
i i'm reading from members that that
it's not considered to be inappropriate
because it doesn't harm the openness if
i've ever got that i think that would be
my reading of
i'd say yes thank you okay
so it's been proposed it's been seconded
i think we go to a vote on it
um will there be a set of conditions to
go with this
i'm not sure what they'll be for offense
they there would be
uh if there were similar conditions that
would need to be
uh perhaps discussed and agreed upon um
yes i'm happy to uh suggest in the same
way as the previous one that headlines
would be
a standard three-year condition um
i would say a schedule of materials
rather than a sample of materials
and i think that's probably all we need
conditions-wise on this
um yeah i think just those two for this
one
and our proposer and second are happy
with those conditions
nodding thank you right let's go to the
vote on this says the
proposal is to grant the application all
those in favor please show
german those against five germans sorry
so
those are gates three no extensions okay
in that case the committee resolves to
grant application reference twenty slash
zero zero seven four five
slash f u l and i happily hand back over
to the chairman
thank you
kendall thank you very much for doing
that um we'll just allow uh mr horton to
make himself at home and set up his
his presentation materials and then we
will get going
are you all settled in tony you need a
couple more minutes
yeah no problem
if anyone wants to very quickly grab a
drink or use the facilities while tony
setting up that's no problem
just literally one minute don't
disappear please
okay and as soon as cancer fielding is
back in his chair we can start again
so while he's making his way over there
um our next item is application
reference 21
0 1 388 ful that's three spring book
lane in town with nardin our presenting
officer is tony horton tony
over to you
you see the context map for the
application
the sites within the general open
countryside
set within the west midlands greenbelt
and part of the arden special landscape
area
this is the location plan so you see the
site edged red
the application site number three is one
half of a pair of semi-detached
dwellings there's another pair
to the south south east
which is numbers one and two and i refer
to those because the applicants have
made reference to these
has been previously extended
you can see the site is
off springbrook lane and there are
a series of other detached dwellings as
you go up the lane
and the development you see there is the
oaks
stables complex
this is the existing plans and
elevations
so the principal elevation the front
elevation as you see there
two-story dwelling and you see from the
side elevation
that there is the flat roof element to
the rear
and that is an extension uh since the
original building
was built so this flat roof
element here which is denoted on the
floor plans
in this purple dashed line
is an extension to the original building
and needs to be taken into consideration
as part of the commutative impact
of extensions to the original building
i don't have the floor plans identifying
what is what in terms of rooms here but
as i understand it
an existing bathroom is here and three
bedrooms
are on first floor
and these are the proposed elevations so
you see the principal elevation the
front elevation
you'll see there's a sliver of an
extension
on the side here which wraps around the
rear
effectively the proposals are to build
above the
existing flat roof ground floor
extension
at first floor level so from the front
elevation you'll only see a
slither of it and because that's set
back
and set down it won't be particularly
noticeable in the street scene
from the side elevation from the
neighbor's vantage points
there's more of the elevation visible
and then you see the most of the bulk
and the mass of the extension would be
visible from the rear
moving on to the floor plans so the
ground floor plan
as i understand matters stays the same
so including the bathroom as existing
there
it's the first floor plan where the
changes come into play
so the extension allows for two new
bedrooms
and for the reconfiguration of what was
a bedroom
into the shower bathroom
facility
this is taken from google street view so
it shows
the application number three uh site
there the dwelling
and you see numbers one two three and
four as
part of their pairs set in the green
belt special landscape
area and you see there's a some detached
bungalows and other dwellings as you go
further up spring
brook lane and then
another google street view image
captured
directly outside number three
[Music]
if you were to i wasn't able to catch it
straight head on but if you were you'd
be able to see this
slightly down the side so you'd be able
to see where the
existing ground floor extension
protrudes and where the
first floor extension would be on the
side but this also come
is here to show you that yes number one
has had extensions to the side in the
rear
as has number two at the rear there and
number four
on the frontage side there
uh chairman i think that concludes the
presentation
other than to say the recommendation is
to refuse planning permission based on
green belt policy because they're
increasing volume of 68
from the original dwelling which makes
it a disproportionate
increase and therefore inappropriate
development in the green belt
thank you tony thank you very much
indeed let's move to our first speaker
who is counselor michael saunders from
tamworth parish
council good evening and welcome thank
you for your patience as we work through
our agenda
you've probably got a reasonable feel
for how things are going to proceed so
you'll have three minutes i'll give you
30 second warning before the end and
that you know when your time is up
um otherwise whenever you're ready feel
free to start
if you could turn on your microphone as
well thank you
to allow it go through the live feed
thank you for listening to me i think
it's fair to say that tamworth parish
council cannot
be considered soft on green belt issues
we have a long record of objecting to
loads of applications
on green bell grounds but on this
occasion we think that the past
decision and this recommendation are
wrong
it's been explained these were two pairs
of semi-detached houses
they were in fact council houses built
in the 1930s
they are very or they were very small
indeed
essentially two up two down um with the
downstairs bathroom
over the last 25 years the other three
have been extended and was one four were
able to bring
down the side as well as at the back um
and number two had the benefit of a
planning permission
only six years ago
the percentage changes in those other
properties
were 150 150
and the one immediately next door and 90
over 90
and as i say that was granted only six
years ago
and although the officer's report says
the core strategy came into effect
um just after that the national planning
policy as regards
extensions to properties in the green
belt um was then enforced
and indeed my understanding of the
effect the core strategy was to slightly
weaker
policy on extensions might be more
flexible
the applicants are understandably rather
upset to find that their application was
refused
but when they bought the house they
assumed they'd be able to do something
similar to the rest and indeed their
proposal
with an overall increase of 68 is
significantly less
than the other three i might point out
that
that 68 figure was only conceded this
afternoon by the case officer
when you previously considered this
application it was described as 88
percent
so my view is a significant difference
it is in fact even though 68 might be
considered a lot
a large percentage of something that is
very small is still going to be very
small indeed
this double story extension that a bit
of which has already been built
would extend no more than 3.5 metres
from the back of the house
and would provide this particular
application by adding that floor would
provide just
a modest bedroom nothing very huge
and a small bathroom to be added to the
existing accommodation
the officer mentions appeal decisions
these are in respect of houses that in
their original state
were far more substantial than this two
three four times bigger
and the additions were proportionately
more significant than 68
the purpose of this aspect of the green
belt policy is to protect
damage to the green belt from loss of
openness council dishonest i'm going to
have to ask you to wrap up if i may it
has been three and i have i'm nearly
finished
and i have to say i cannot see how the
addition of the
first floor extension on this property
is going to seriously damage
um the green belt every month the parish
council was asked to comment or next
time i i am going to have to stop you
there now i'm afraid
um that is a good 20 seconds over now um
members do we have any questions for our
parish council please
cancel crump hello cancer saunders
uh very briefly um on page 27 of the
report it says the
talmud nard neighborhood plan which is
obviously pre-submission
policy h6 states that extensions to
existing dwellings will normally
only be supported well the volume of the
extension is no more than 30 percent of
the running
as it existed in 1975. so
on this case you're saying that this is
the exception to that
because you would normally for things
been equal
uh not support an extension of this size
well it's it's it's not a made
neighborhood development plan we haven't
had the examination in public
and that proposal is an effort to deal
with
the issue of maintaining a balanced
stock of housing and has nothing to do
with green belt policy we are at odds in
the in
formal consultations we have your
officers at odds over this
and i think it's an issue which you know
will benefit from further thought
i don't think it's relevant to this
application okay thank you council
jennings next please
thank you um obviously you know the
property
are there any parts or rights of way
behind the property can you see this
um property from behind the applicant is
going to speak and i think she
she knows more about it than i do no
problem at all
are there any neighbours objecting to
this development
and all three neighbors supporting okay
that's all i need to know thank you
marvelous i don't think there are any
other questions for our members no in
that case
thank you very much
sorry
[Music]
okay our next speaker then uh is mr
jerome who is our applicant would you
like to make your way forward
so welcome good evening um i think again
you've probably got
an understanding of what's going to
happen now three minutes 30 second
warning
when you're ready uh if you press the
button in the middle at the bottom it'll
turn on and go red
yeah whenever you're ready good evening
thank you for allowing me to be here
today to present our case on behalf of
myself and my husband
he is unfortunately unable to attend due
to current pressures on the nhs
but he was unable but he's attended his
apologies
we are very grateful for this
opportunity and for the support of the
parish councillor
parish council our ward councillor tony
dixon and our neighbours at numbers one
two and four who have all written
letters in support of our application
our principal motivation for our
application is that we are hoping to
start a family and do not have an upset
bathroom
this is a universal need and nowadays is
certainly considered normal and a basic
requirement for modern living
but it's of course essential for for a
young family
our home sits as one of four dwellings
in two sets of council built
semi-detached properties
of which all the other three houses have
already been extended because they were
originally very small
as shown in these photos numbers one and
four have been
previously granted permission to extend
to the side and to the rear by over 150
of their original footprint with number
four also having a conservatory
having previously extended at ground
floor level and built a garage to the
side
the first floor extension at number two
was built in 2015 so that they could
install an upstairs bathroom
bringing their total percentage increase
to 90 percent
2015 was a time when the council applied
to 30
maximum threshold under greenbelt policy
despite this their application was
granted
at committee stage suggesting that there
must be an overriding agreement
that an upstairs bathroom is essential
and that their extension would not
negatively harm the greenbelt
area out of the four properties number
three has been
has been extended significantly less
with just a ground floor kitchen and
utility extension to the rear in 2006.
this is because our home is constrained
and is very narrow in comp
in comparison which is why our extension
is primarily to the rear with no
increase whatsoever
to the existing footprint it will sit
directly above the kitchen
which much like a smaller version of
number two
as ours is only a 68 total increase will
have very limited
impact on greenbelt open openness or the
environment
with no loss to hedges trees or
vegetation the extension will hardly be
noticeable from the front
and as our home benefits from a long
garden of 32 metres an open countryside
to the rear
again minimal impact although on paper
the percentage may seem high
given that the original footprint of the
house was so small this is not a large
extension and so our house will always
remain within the affordable pricing
range
30 seconds a specific maximum figure for
greenbelt policy is in many senses
considered arbitrary
and a more appropriate means of
maintaining openness is to consider
proposals on a case-by-case basis
we firmly believe that given the history
on springbrook lane
and the need for an upstairs bathroom
that there's a clear precedent for the
greenbelt restriction to be mitigated
as our proposed plans are appropriate
for the locality and will not negatively
harm the openness and visual immunity of
the greenbelt area
thank you for listening 21 milliseconds
over so well done
you're fine that's well done indeed
members do we have any questions for mr
owen
council jennings is going to be a
surprise for you
is it visible from behind are there any
paths or lights
no that's um separate land it belongs to
the stable so it's just horse
paddocks
thank you any other questions members
can't send your serpent okay sure
how long have you lived there we bought
the prop we bought
it in 2016.
yeah and you like living there you don't
want to move
yeah you want a family home counseling
members do we have any other questions
that are relevant planning matters
no mr thank you very much
our next speaker and take as much time
as you need to any as is of course our
war member counselor dixon
so as soon as you're ready you can come
forward
and cancel dixon you definitely know the
drill five minutes 30 seconds use as
much
or as little as that five minutes as you
require
thank you chairman and thank you tony
for doing a splendid presentation which
i think you
uh used in your description uh a sliver
of the side extension could be viewed
from the road
um essentially what we're talking about
here is
not the volume the increase
because obviously volume is not what is
actually
important it is the impact on the
potential harm
of the openness of the green belt
lindsay young in her report
makes reference to an appeal
in respect of haystacks where the
inspector turned down
and she's used that to reference an 80
increase in that property you heard from
the parish councillor
mike saunders that you know if you start
with a small property and you
increase it by 80 you don't necessarily
get a very large property but if you
start with something like haystacks
which was a large house in a large plot
and you increase it by 80
you do put massive increase on there
and in the inspectors words you know the
proposed extensions would add
notice of bulk and massing to the
property and would result in the
original
dwelling being engulfed in extensions
this property this application tonight
is not
an engulfing of a property there is a
single storey rear
extension and all the applicants want to
do is to put a first floor above it
and create a family home with a bathroom
in the first floor i'll keep it brief
another property and another appeal not
appeal decision
a delegated decision this one this is
the property around the corner from
haystacks
and i quote from that recent local
planning consent
approved under delegated authority
the existing dwelling is considered to
be approximately
77 larger than the original dwelling at
present
the proposed extensions would take the
total volumetric increase
to 92 percent when taking into account
the visual impact of the dwellings
presence
the cumulative impact of the proposal is
unlikely to detrimentally impact the
openness of the greenbelt
to a harmful extent that was granted
because the planner
considered the volume not the volume
but the impact of the proposal
members i am very much of the opinion
that this application tonight
is similarly unlikely to detrimentally
impact
the openness of the green belt to a
harmful extent
i therefore ask that you grant this
application thank you chairman
thank you very much councillor members
do we have any questions for our world
member please
no lucky in that case council dixon
thank you very much you may take make
you leave
right we'll move then two points for
clarification for our officers
who would like to kick us off with that
councillor crump first please
tony very briefly i'm on page 27
the previous application the exact same
was refused
was that a committee one or was i not
sir a delegated
refusal please
i apologize i just missed the first part
you said the previous refusal
yeah was that was that an officer
delegation or was it iem committee one
as i understand it um both the
previous refusal and the refusal in 2004
were both officer
um the delegate and items okay thank you
anyone else have a point of
clarification i've got a couple
i think um tony we heard
from uh various speakers that uh numbers
one
two and four have all had quite
significant extensions
um specifically i wanted to ask about
number two and there was a
it was intimated that it has increased
by 90 percent as
as uh close to six years ago
um can you give me a bit more
information about that please
yes certainly chairman so to spring
brook lane
it had a two-story rear extension in
2000
and it had a garage extension in 2005
and then more recently in 2015
item came to planning committee with a
recommendation for refusal
based on excess not being small scale
commutatively in the green belt members
uh
overturned that recommendation i do
actually have the reason
for the overturn uh which stated amongst
other wording
it says given the balancing effect that
the development would have
on the semi-detached dwellings
and given that the footprint of the
existing building would not be increased
that very special circumstances exist to
outweigh the harm that would have been
so that's the history of the number two
so a 2001
based on an old policy 2005 an old
policy
in 2015 on the previous policy to the
current core strategy
thank you very much indeed we also heard
that
uh i i think i got this right um that
upstairs bathrooms are now deemed to be
an essential requirement
um first i've heard of that is that a
planning consideration is that planning
policy
um or is that just a basic sort of
we've got no specific planning policy
which says the bathroom has to be
provided upstairs
there are many properties within the
district with downstairs bathroom
facilities only
okay lovely thank you um in that case if
no other member has a point of
clarification we'll move to the debate
who would like to kick us off please
someone put their hand up or i'm going
to start picking on people
council jennings first
well on this one and houses built in the
1930s
um we're very small not really
appropriate now
i'm having an upstairs toilet to me
seemed like a reasonable
reasonable expectation um
the 30 rule um is only a guide
it's uh it enables us to judge each
application on its own merits
um we don't need special circumstances
if we think the application is
appropriate
um in this case
i'm sorry i feel that the application
is appropriate from my point of view
interested to hear other members
opinions council candle
thank you sorry i was getting bit
difficult stuck i'll try to put the hand
about trying to press this i'll be
beating you to it otherwise i think
castle jennings um
look i think we've looked at these sort
of things before actually and i think
it's about whether or not we find this
to be
having any meaningful impact on the on
the green belt
especially given the effect of of all
the other houses around there
i don't think this has any meaningful
effect and i think it's entirely
reasonable
uh to allow this sort of extension to
what is a small property a number of
people said things that
you know chimed quite nicely yeah 68 of
a very small house is actually you know
it's still
quite a small amount and i can't see the
justification
for refusing that so i'm happy to
propose that we
actually grant this application uh my
specific reasoning will
is along the lines of it will not
detrimentally impact the openness of the
green belt
as council dixon suggested i think
mars thanks very much castle fleming um
risking the wrath of um some some other
people within the
in the committee um this isn't the first
time she's come up in the last few
months
not this particular application and now
we're not supposed to harp back on what
we did before
but we've done exactly this before not
many months ago
um a small x local authority house
which are small and then it's the
cumulative
thing you know the house was built in
1930 somebody built a piece on it in
1970.
the whole point about it is modern
families need modern living space
um and the upstairs bathroom is a huge
consideration for a young
family the effect on the green belt's
neither here nor there as far as i can
see
in actual fact this house doesn't comply
with the street scene compared to the
other three
so so from that perspective i would i
would back any
any to to actually grant this
application
is that a formal second thing if it's
not don't worry because i probably will
in a second
yes i'll say marvelous so formal
secondly so we've had a proposal
to uh to grant uh scandal seconded by
cancer fleming
um i'm in general agreement with you
i think um for me you know 68 yes
from us of a small item is still a small
amount but
we do have guides um we need to be
mindful of that
council fleming you're saying about
other decisions we made previously we
all know
um and i know that you're well aware of
this we must consider each on their
individual
merits particularly in the green belt
where special circumstances come into
play
for me um clearly we have
to kind of phrase it cancer dixon said
engulfed by extensions engulfed in
extensions on a previous property this
for me feels almost like it's being
engulfed by
other people's extensions why on earth
would we prevent
this property from being able to extend
similar
similar to um tony's comment as well
uh where another dwelling was considered
uh okay because in balancing in the
street scene and the other properties
but also
there's no increase in footprint as i
understand it there is no increasing
footprint here and certainly wouldn't be
significant if there is anything but i
don't think there is
so in my mind either it's inappropriate
and we have all of those as special
circumstances or
all of those are very good reasons for
us to go against the officer's
recommendation
either way i've come to the same
conclusion the reason i've said all that
is for uh richard to be able to write
down our reasons
did you get all that or do you want me
to say it again
yeah it seems to me that that members
are in a position where they consider
it's not inappropriate development in
the first place and don't need very
special circumstances
and it seems to me the reason that
you're saying it's not inappropriate
is because it doesn't harm the openness
and you do consider that in this case 68
is small scale i i think we should also
uh stress the point that is in my mind
and it's up to the proposal and second
of course
in my mind that um uh the the fact that
there's no increase in footprint
um goes along with supporting saying
it's not inappropriate in the
green belt um what was the other thing i
said i can't remember now
um some of the other things you said
were more very special circumstances
which which is you know equally by
virtue of the positioning in in relation
to the
other other properties on the street
scene it's not considered you've been
approached
you're only going to need those if if
you've decided that it's inappropriate
and you haven't decided it's
inappropriate
you're happy with the footprint thing
being added i'm happy delighted
yeah yep okay perfect in that case um
do we need to consider conditions
standard conditions everything has to be
delegated
or wording off to be delegated
i would suggest chairman
that final wording delegated to officers
but
three-year commencement number one
number two
relating to the relevant plans submitted
number three matching materials
uh number four climate change measures
implementation and the note number one
about working with the applicants on the
mppf
thank you very much happy with those
because i'm happy with those
yeah perfect lovely stuff in that case
let's take a vote so um
i know you're gonna need my numbers in
place again so uh application reference
twenty one zero one
three eight eight ful the proposal is to
grant the reasons given with the
conditions that we've just heard but i
show
hands for those in favor please
marvelous in that case uh committee
resolves to grant application twenty one
zero one three eight eight
f u l excellent right
we'll move then to our last application
of the evening which is twenty one zero
one zero eight
two f u l that is nineteen word road in
wells born our plenty of opportunities
once again
tony horton tony over to you
thank you chairman see the context map
and the applicant site is within the
built-up area
of wellspawn which is one of the main
rural settlements of the district
you see this site which is edged in
black there
it's on the north side of warwick road
it's half
of a pair of semi-detached properties
understood to be from the 1920s
and it's set back from the warwick road
and it fronts the boundary of the
conservation area so that pink line is
the conservation area boundary
so the site's not in it but facing to it
and therefore potentially affecting the
setting
of the conservation area in the
consideration of matters
the existing
plans and elevations
so floor plans so you see it's
relatively modest property with
single living room which is effectively
a through room with windows
front and back kitchen and upstairs we
have
two bedrooms and bathroom and
elevationally
existing front elevation
elevation side elevation with four
windows facing directly to the
neighbouring property
and then the proposed plans and
elevations
so ground floor you see we have
a wraparound extension to to the rear of
the
existing dwelling now which wraps around
the side
to a small extent and then at first
floor
we have
the two-story element of it which is
to create bedroom one here with ensuite
and wardrobe space
and you'll know the elements here is not
too story
it's just a single story here because of
the neighbor's window potentially being
affected
by matters in terms of elevations this
is the front elevation
so you'll see the wrap around two-story
element of it
is visible albeit that it's set back and
i'll give you some dimensions of that
in a moment set down and set away from
the boundary
and then the main bulk of the extension
you'll see
from the rear so you've got the single
storage element
which sets down to have less impact on
the neighbors
windows and then on the side
you did have four windows you now have
effectively
glassing in the doorway a high level
kitchen window
and a bathroom window which would
imagine that the applicants would want
to
obscure a glaze and then i move on to
some
photo i've got the the
block plan here and i've annotated this
with the
dimensions so the existing running set a
long way
back from the the pay back end of
pavements
8.2 meters the extension itself
is set back 1.8 meters from the frontage
of the original building
and it's also set down by 0.9 meters
from the original ridge height so in
terms of
subservience it does the jobs in being
set back and set down
and then in terms of the issue of the
potential terracing impacts
it's only about 1.575 metres wide it
leaves
a gap of around about 1.6 meters to its
boundary
with number 17 to the side and number 17
itself has a three meter distance
between that and the boundary between
the two properties so effectively
it might with the extension in place it
still maintains a 4.6 meter
gap between the properties to overcome
the issue of potential terracing
and then photograph of the rear so you
can see the existing
uh setup with the the neighbours window
that's potentially affected so the
single story elements here
two story elements here wrapping around
the side
and then from the front so you'll have
the relatively narrow side extent
two-story side extension which then
wraps around the back
maintaining three 4.6 meter gap between
the two
and then in street scene terms looking
from the south east
so number 19 is here you won't really
get any sense of the extension from that
direction
and from the opposite vantage points
looking towards those
semis number 19 is there and
because the extension will be set down
set back
probably from this view you wouldn't
even see the extension but
you would as you obviously went further
down the road
chairman i think that's all i need to
say
on the application the matters
of design impacts on the street scene
setting up the conservation area
and impacts on the neighbours
immediately are being considered and the
recommendation is to grant permission
thank you thank you very much and tease
right let's have our first
speaker on this item which is council
and prior councillor prior do you come
on forward please
welcome and good evening again thank you
for your patience
um so you i think you know the drill
again three minutes 30 seconds
middle button will turn the microphone
on it'll go red whenever you're ready
over to you oh good evening everybody
the parish council wishes to object to
this application we spent
some considerable time actually debating
this development
we fully support the rear extension i
would start by saying that
um because we believe that it increases
the amenities for the resident
and doesn't impact detrimentally on the
street scene or neighboring properties
however we object to this application
due to the side extension
the report notes the significance of
this row of houses they were actually
the first council houses to be built in
wells born
in 1923-24 and given the historical
period and desire to build houses as
they said then fit for heroes
they're well spaced and have good garden
and open space around them
and this development would despite being
to quote the report
so a subservient design would destroy
the unique features of this row of
houses detracting from the street scene
creating an anomalous house in a row of
houses
none of which have a side extension many
have garages that have been constructed
but these are to the rear of the houses
there is no development of this nature
in this row
of properties we're concerned as a
parish council that giving permission
for this site extension
would cause a precedent and would
further develop and further such
developments could lead
to a terrorist-like row of houses
instead of the current well-spaced
semi-detached properties that we have
we would therefore ask that you reject
this application
council brian thank you very much that
was well within your time uh members do
we have any questions for cancer prior
please
no oh counselor jennings thank you very
much
just to confirm this row of houses
they're not protected by any listings
are they
no okay thank you okay
in that case cancer pry thank you very
much for your contribution
okay members our next speaker is our
applicant who is mr tony sheridan mr
sheridan please do come on forward
good evening and welcome again thank you
very much your patience
no problem
so i think again you've probably got the
uh a run of things so three minutes i'll
give you 30 second warning when you're
all ready
the house as it stands itself is really
a two up two down
um we are struggling to get
a double bed in the front bedroom and
also the side bedroom
we struggle to get a double bed in there
as well what we're proposing
with also putting in the window at the
front is that we're going to do away
with the side window which actually
overlooks a bedroom next door
and no more of this distance between the
tables
the slight extension we're putting on
the side
it's five foot and it's set back six
foot
so you won't unless you stand in front
of the house you're not going to see it
um it's not a listed building and it's
not in the conservation area so
i'm just hoping that you know you'll
grant us it
i think that's about all god sorry just
bear with me a second i'm getting i'm
being spoken thank you
sorry we just we weren't sure because
normally we have these little
things on top so i can see whether your
mic's on or not
i saw you press the button yeah but we
couldn't be sure so i could hear myself
don't panic um okay members uh sorry
about that do we have any questions for
mr sheridan please cancel hence yourself
in first yeah thank you
are there any neighbours objecting no no
not at all
and we do have carriages that are
actually at the front so if you look at
it it's not going to be a terrorist
effect
we we meet in what is currently required
okay
yeah so thank you thank you marvelous if
there are any other questions
doesn't look like it sheridan thank you
very much thank you
so our final speaker of the evening will
be councillor parry good evening
councillor parry i'll give you a couple
of seconds to make your way up and make
yourself comfortable
and again good evening again nice to be
back
well i'm misting up now
[Laughter]
okay no it is lovely to see you all and
thank you chair no problem
five minutes i'll give you 30 second
warning when you're ready i won't need
five minutes
um what i just wanted to say is whilst
i'm sympathetic
to the comments raised by the parish
council
they they take a lot of time and effort
looking at plans
very very diligently
i've been to have a look at this and i
can't find
a material planning reason to refuse
having visited the site there's
currently quite a bit of extensive
refurbishment that's actually going on
um and from my perspective looking at
from the road
i felt there was more than significant
space in fact
um you know it's it
most applicants would have decided to
make up a much
larger side extension than just five
foot because there is extensive
area there um i do feel
in view of the property it would
certainly enhance the immunity
for the applicants um
i think my only request is
if you're considering granting this is
that the
design and aesthetics of the materials
used
and the paint render um is retained to
match
the rest of the
pairs of houses in this stretch so it
doesn't have an
impact on the street scene
because i think it's important that we
do retain that design and look
um but i'm sitting here and i couldn't
see a planning reason
material reason to refuse over to you
guys
castle parry thank you very much indeed
members do you have any questions for
council barry
i thought richard put his hand up then
no council fleming
uh okay surprise that was very
eloquently put can we take that as a
proposal
okay if there are no questions sorry
council and famine i'm no longer sitting
on the planning committee
due to my other responsibilities as
there are no questions councilor perry
thank you very much thank you your
patience as well as you've watched
everything tonight
so thank you very much members let's
move to points clarification to the
offices i will start with one if i may i
can see there is a
condition for materials as submitted do
those materials match
what is there now
i believe they do chairman if you see
the front elevation here
the um the key that's normally used for
render
is this kind of speckled
element and then it looks brick uh
along the uh the print plinth which
would match the uh
the proposal with the existing so
we can double check on that if you want
to give
officers authority to make sure that the
materials are matching
or we could condition that materials
match i'm entirely happy to give you
that authority that was going to be my
next question do we need to condition it
or can i give you authority you've
answered the question so yes i'm happy
to give that authority
if we grant
casa dixon please
your question preceded mine it was
exactly the same
marvelous cancer feeling i'm
fascinated to know what a bad note is
what does exactly what does that exactly
mean
this would be something that would be
requested by the county
ecology unit it normally um
is a an opening for a bat to
to make use of for roosting purposes
the bird the bird or sometimes
i don't know exactly what what the bird
note is i think it's
because they're potentially affecting
the roof element of it
it may be that it's to protect nesting
birds or
roosting bats i don't know whether
richard you would know what the standard
note says
um yeah in both cases it's just to put a
marker down
under the wildlife and countryside at
birds that are nesting
and bats that are roosting and protected
so if any are discovered during
construction
work has to stop while a qualified
ecology comes out and takes measures
but it's not under the planning act
which is why it only appears as a note
i did not know that's the word i did not
know that either so that's quite
informative
casserole next please just a very quick
one thank you chair uh could
could i see the photo from the front
elevation please again
you put during the presentation
that's the one thank you that's it
that's simple uh any other questions
points clarification no
okay let's move to debate who wants to
kick us off councillor jennings
and this one is rather houses they're
not protected by any listings
um principle of development is there
unless there's a good reason
not to go with it um i see no valid plan
and reason to go against the officer's
decision
on this matter and i'm very happy to
propose that
we grant marvelous thank you very much i
think i'm going to second that
um i do have sympathy with the parish
council's
uh comments and statements but for me
the the the foreign
half i think is meter gap maintains um
an appropriate street scene so i'm happy
to second that um unless anyone else has
anything they want to say we'll move to
a vote
no good let's go to a vote
um can we help those in favor please
put your hand up
marvelous in that case committee
resolves to grant application twenty one
zero
one zero eight two f you united mark
road in wells born
um we don't have any urgent business but
i would like it put on note i'm sure you
already know
um uh councillor rolfe was taken ill
last week
she has undergone surgery today i don't
yet know
how she is after that but i think we
want it put on record and i'm sure you
all share the sentiment that we wish her
very well in getting back uh to to
normal
so thank you very much indeed and we
will close meeting there thank you
everyone
you